[Music]
Kristen and I Dina you put on Instagram
we owed you 20 bucks see where they owe
you this money love you so much
what cuz I gave him money at the valet
last night oh so he's not counting that
okay yes so clearly Josh GAD isn't
letting that one yo see what they did
there but does Kristen Bell have a
different kind of beef with the original
movie it's one of the many frozen facts
the cast reveal to power nischelle
Turner we have too much fun together
like if we all hated each other we'd be
like yeah I enjoy the movie good night
I've never been better
this is so nice that songs are
extraordinarily written I think that
they are beautiful they tell the story
of these characters I won't let anything
happen to her
you didn't ask me about my critiques the
frozen one but I'll tell you haha we
didn't get enough Jonathan Groff singing
I would listen to him sing the alphabet
forever but people smell better than
reindeers this time we get 7 new socks
and several new characters
Shirley K Brown is a lieutenant Evan
Rachel Wood plays the girl's mom Queen
adieu na good to hear me singing this
yes
Disney taught me how to sing you know
dizzy raised me so to be able to sing in
one of their films in an animated film
to lend my voice it just feels full
circle
[Music]
past is not what it seems being in a
sequel to the 1 billion dollar-plus film
allowed sterling to score some cool dad
points with his two boys I think if the
movie is everything that I hope and know
that it will be I think they'll be
really excited to say like my dad's a
part of that Olof himself Josh GAD got
two kids of his own how does he handle
meltdowns he calls it the foot tap
technique please come here baby you
gently tap tap them and then you ask
them are you ready now is it okay i
thoughtyou
they're hulking out use your toe not
your hand
[Music]